boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
really excited to still be on-site in
New York City New York we are now going
to be talking about all things related a
comedy all things related to working
your ass off 600 plus shows a year and I
am or hi I'm hired as I drink my coffee
we're super excited to have Harrison
Greenbaum joining us on the show thank
you so much thank you I'm excited really
pumped really yeah so let's give a quick
background on Harrison Harrison's got
multi award-winning comedian over the
last 13 years he had a huge magic
inspiration growing up as well he's done
America's Got Talent he's done Conan
he's done Last Comic Standing from a lot
of reality shows
but also that's really crucial to
persevere and get up to those rankings
as well and test yourself
he's also the host of what's your
problem which is a very funny show we're
gonna three talk a little bit as well
and yes he does over 600 shows a year
which it makes him one of the most
in-demand comedians in New York City
it's thank you yeah it's weird to be and
this is like we're in a Shackleton
themed bar and so like that guy what
survived the Antarctic like or
Antarctica right he survived it for like
seven months and like he didn't lose a
man I'm like oh I did 600 combo like it
pales in comparison to Shackleton I feel
like like his influences uh but it's
cold so it's keeping me awake that's
perfect yeah yeah yeah and here's a
couple things that I think are really
important for Harrison to touch on
Harrison's got you now that he has these
tons of years of experience and tons of
shows under his belt I really want us to
first take like a big history look at
civilization okay humans find themselves
the stewards of earth now your real on
transition right here's your background
as a comedian now tell me everything
about the history of civilization well I
don't know if I make it easier I'll make
it easier so we have this big history
look at civilization and here we find
ourselves as stewards now we live in a
very complex world seven point seven
billion people now a lot we hockey stick
tup in population we got exponential
technologies yeah yeah so tell us about
your thoughts on the current
state of things I mean I think it's hard
for me to take any kind of bird's-eye
view because I've the slice of
civilization that I've experienced is
even if you include the experience that
I've learned through my grandparents
whatever it's so small overall I do
think there is that exponential growth
like that's what you look for with
technology and at some point there's
there's an inflection point where it
goes like straight vertical right or
almost vertical and I think I would like
I think we're probably if I had to guess
like I'm coming around the inflection
point like we're gonna hit that straight
vertical or that near vertical you know
if it went straight up there'd be no
change of value third time would stop
but if it was so that's that's a crazy
thing to think that we might have made
it like no other group or or era or
generation has gotten that I guess the
just to be able to experience that part
where the growth is that quick who knows
maybe we did it maybe this is just a we
were just coming around the bend but
yeah I think that the development of
technology it seems interesting it feels
to me because I'm a big tech geek and I
all I do is like
retexe and look at what's the latest
gadget and what's happening at CES you
know that kind of stuff and it seems
that we're at a point now where it's not
like you dream it and then you have to
come up with the technology is that
there's so much technology available
it's just about finding a company who's
willing to like put it together in the
package that it meets like you can make
a smart refrigerator if you want the
technology definitely exists and that
was a question of whether a refrigerator
company wants to use the technology
that's already there so it's kind of
interesting that you can kind of the
technology that was ahead of the dreams
at this point like you can dream a thing
like oh I have all the technology to do
that not to say that we're not gonna
push it even further but it seems really
cool that like essentially all the
things that I saw as a kid in sci-fi
movies yeah like is I remember watching
big that was a big moment for me where I
realized Tech was really accelerating
was I as a kid I was watching big and he
had a living comic book and then the
iPad came out I was like I think I just
got the thing that Tom Hanks has okay I
think I now own the thing that I wanted
as a boy and it's here and it does more
than just being a comic book but this is
touches one of the things this thing
does so I think yeah we're at the point
now where it's it really is like our
dreams are almost falling behind the
pace of Technology because technology is
accelerating so fast
and hopefully we'll have that next
moment where we're like we're excited
for flying cars and then in a couple
decades it's like boom like the normal
the normality is flying cars or that the
we're excited for preventive medicine so
we don't have to be Alzheimer's and
cancer and all this kind of stuff
medically I mean that's the Ray Kurzweil
thing of like reaching that point where
we're either the last generation to die
or the first generation not to yeah
that's what it feels like you know it'll
be really suck over the last die yeah
yeah and there's our kids who are like
we're gonna live forever like god damn
or if we're the first were the first
generation to not die but we haven't
gotten any of the anti-aging so we're
the only old people on earth forever
forever we're gonna be like 90 years old
and everybody's gonna be gorgeous
and then you have to hope we come some
kind of fetish that people are like oh I
I'm really into the world feels really
people are so rare that would really
that would be the worst-case scenario I
would love to live forever I guess
long that could be like oh there's no
like oh Henry Twist to living forever
but man if I get to live forever but
they have to be in the 90 year old body
when everybody else is at a 20 year old
body that does not see that does not
seem unfair Harrison I think a good
question to follow up with you on this
would be what are some of the you you
would you indicated that the hockey
stick and we're riding along and we're
at that inflection point
well now what would you say are some of
these pressing issues that we need to as
a unity as a civilization make sure that
we have ironed out well I be in it I'm
no expert I'm literally a stand-up
comedian but I I do think that one of
the dangers of anytime you accelerate
through something like with any process
is that there is a sort of there's a
processing speed that happens within
within each of us of how fast we can
process information and developing us
and then as you add more and more people
cuz I was a psych major in college we
study the intergroup dynamics the more
people you add the slower the overall
processing time is like we I was in a
class there's actually a possible part
of the Harvard Business School and we
were talking about you know like how did
how many people should be an
organization how do you organize your
organization
and you find that you know there are
some orchestras that don't have a
conductor there's this one organ circle
or feeis they don't have a conductor
everything that's done to democratically
and it's cool and it works but it takes
them a lot longer to make a decision
because there's not one conductor to be
like no we're doing it this way and so
there's benefits to both ways that
sounds like shine in the US with a
conductor and without a conductor I mean
they definitely have a court this way
yeah I mean I but I think we have it the
same thing we're the reason you have a
president and you don't just have
Congress I can't part of it but I think
one of the reasons you do that is
because of that processing power is you
do need it so event that's thing with
juries like is 12 people the right
number like if you put 18 people on the
jury you might be better off in terms of
it's more gonna reflect the opinion of
America at large the more people you add
just the more reflective it'll be of the
population but at a certain point
nothing will get done you'll never get
it during the degrees on anything if you
have a thousand people in the jury but
soon so I think that's the issue is
right now there the speed is rapidly
increasing we the amount of technology
that's coming out is rapidly increasing
but the number of people is increasing
and so the processing time is going down
your billions of people in just the last
couple you try to get a billion people
to agree on something it will take
forever so there is this danger of like
not having agreement on everything or BR
making it very difficult for people to
just agree because there's more people
and more opinions and so we don't want
to ever get to a point where like you
get you there's a danger of one guy
making a decision or one girl making a
decision that like has a very negative
effect on a lot of people and he gets to
do it because he's made the decision and
done it before anybody else make wait
what I'm sorry it sounds like some of
the algorithms for the two billion
people that use YouTube and Facebook
that's what this sounds like when when
just a handful of people are in charge
of two billion human animals perception
on social platforms well that's a whole
other thing is that now the tools it
used to be that you could a small group
where people couldn't own a tool that
had that much kind of rete like so there
are we now have tools that will reach a
billion people instantly or eight I mean
seven billion people instantly and yeah
that kind of power is something no human
has had before like that's that you had
a newspaper Baron but how many
the newspaper Baron how many eyeballs
that he really control and he was
considered very powerful so I think yeah
there's a lot of danger in that and
there is no I don't know that there's
there's no easy or Pat answer for how do
you regulate and how do you control and
make sure that nobody gets hurt yeah
it's gonna be tough for us to figure out
how to prosper collectively but it's the
most important thing we can figure out
how to love each other and move forward
together cohesively as a single earth
tribe well I think that's that's like
such a perfect thing because like my
thesis in college was on race related
humor and its effect on prejudice and so
as I did a lot of research on prejudice
racism all that kind of thing and the
main factor in anything misogyny
homophobia it's in group versus out
group so what you define is your
in-group is your group and then you kind
of the out group is and is outside of
you and so they get hurt it doesn't
matter in a way like you it's how we're
tribally built and if we define the
in-group as humanity it's a lot better
people are a lot better to each other
because we're all the in-group exactly
and there's this whole practice of
learning how to really do a really good
job at getting behind someone else's
eyes and seeing how they've lived a life
and absorb stimuli through their life
through their 10 years 50 years 100
years however old they are and then be
able to really gain that sense of oh
this is how you got the belief systems
that you've had and really carry that on
to other people and fundamental
attribution error but not falling victim
to FAA like realizing that I mean
fundamental attribution error I'm sure
you familiar but like the idea of that
for anybody who wasn't a dirty psych
major like I was basically the idea is
the biggest error we make according to
psychologists is like the fundamental
attribution error is that we tend to
attribute behavior to internal things so
the guy was mean to me because he's an
[ __ ]
can I say that word of cool okay yes so
but baby that guy's mean to me because
he had a really really shitty day he's
actually the nicest person in the world
but you kind of on the one bad day where
something terrible's going on with this
family or how awful and so that like
anybody would be in a bad mood and
instead of saying he's a he's a bad
person because he's in a bad mood maybe
he's a great person and once you
recognize what FA e is yeah it really
makes you I think a better person I have
to sometimes step back I screw it up all
the time but it's like realizing if
somebody does something that it's not
maybe not who they are it's the
environment or the something external
and that also helps you relate more to a
person maybe that person is it doesn't
mean to be mean to me he's actually a
really nice person but he's just has
circumstances around him that are
causing him to be mean in this moment
yep yep that's always a slow down and
really cognize and think instead of
immediately react and that's the whole
process of meditation as well that can
help us with that I'm glad you brought
up fundamental attribution errors and
actually this all kind of ties okay
let's transition now you did psyche you
did psyche at Harvard but besides that
you also started the Harvard stand-up
comedians it was a Harvard it was really
the Harvard stand-up comic society those
Harvard sucks is the acronym they had of
comic Society yeah so we so knit the
paper work so I submit the paper work
but I'm like I'm not if I write Harvard
sucks on the application they're
immediately gonna be like no you can't
do that it's like I'm gonna painfully
write out the Harvard stand-up comic
Society I'm never gonna use the acronym
at any point of the paper work just
gonna write it out every time so I send
in the paperwork and you know you wait
you get an email from the dean's office
we need to see you about the paperwork
I'm like damn it they figured it out and
they start this [ __ ] they're smart so I
go in they go yeah it's the name and I
go damn it they go you're actually an
undergrad organization so it should be
the Harvard College stand-up comic
Society
do you mind changing it will approve it
right away and I was like oh my god they
did not see this so we became Harvard
College sucks which is just as funny and
then like years later I ran into
somebody in the dean's office who was
like we obviously when you were student
we couldn't tell you this but goddamn
that was like the funniest prank someone
ever pulled off on us we're like you
totally got us we did not see it the
only reason they knew it was Harvard
College sucks was after the organization
been around for a few months we applied
to the trademark office because you want
to print up a sweat shirt that has
Harvard on it you got to get approval
because it's their logo and their brand
so you just send in a request like a man
to make teacher
they're gonna say Harvard it's for our
group on campus so we send in the design
and it says like Harvard sucks on it
like Harvard College sucks on it and
they were like oh god damn it
no we did that's when I got the angry
email weather like god we can't take
their approval back but you got us so
yeah it was it was a fun it was a fun
time and so the first Sofer there's a
couple things that I want to get to as
you know you're really going hard
because Harvard is tough to get into and
you start surrounding yourself with
really intelligent diverse people from
around the world yeah so there's like a
really there's like a salient moment in
life for you right there where you're
like wow I went from being really really
smart in high school to being one of so
many smart people yeah yes - tell us
about that moment I mean it's great like
you feel I mean obviously it you it's
we're talk about tribes like you walk
into Harvard and everybody like all the
sudden you're like oh like I can say
that big word and not have to explain it
to anybody else I know it sounds like
harp like there's that sense of okay
like we're all on the level and I
thought everybody at Harvard is smart
they're definitely not there are
legacies but they're there they're
athletes
um no they're almost everybody there is
very smart but it's not to say also that
like people who don't get in aren't
smart like that's the we crazy thing
about Harvard is there's so much luck
because I think I think the statistic
that I heard it's probably changed a lot
but 20,000 people apply it's probably
lot more now but 20,000 people apply it
I think when I applied and like 16,000
of em would be considered academically
eligible so like the vast majority are
considered smart enough to do the
coursework and do well at Harvard yeah
damn 16 out of 20,000 yeah so then how
do you from that 16,000 how do you find
the 1500 - oh that is actually gonna get
in so there there's all these other
factors of like oh are you really good
at this thing you know I always yeah
clearly say being what was it being
there you to be well-rounded that's one
thing when there's the there's some I've
read the phrasing there's like an
admissions officer described it where
it's like being really well unrounded
where it's like you're so good at this
one thing that like we should put you in
the class because you're the best figure
skater in the world or you're the best
but I noticed or
yeah you invented this thing that they
use in knee replacement surgery whatever
it is yeah so finding those people are
really good for the class too and I
always felt like my whole job was to
discover what everybody's superpower was
you know cuz everybody had it a saying
how are ya
you'd be like you'll be talking to
somebody I remember I was trying to ask
her on a date was like we should go
ice-skating I'm a terrible ice skater
but I was like I done it a couple times
I go I can show you some tricks that I
picked up and she was like an Olympic
level figures game I had no idea she was
so kind you just like I mean like I've
done it before or I'm like oh really
where have you done it and she was like
I mean like at the Olympics oh [ __ ] god
dammit
you should be teaching me obviously and
I'm gonna fall on my face so like
everybody has that everyone else a cool
thing to be yeah now now you attribute a
lot of your interest initially in comedy
to your grandfather so tell us about the
comedy & magic interest when you were
young and how that went in through
Harvard into now yeah I mean I I've been
very lucky I only had three grandparents
my grandfather passed away before I was
born so my name is Harrison which is
based on Harold
so I've named after the one grandfather
if it didn't make it but you have my
paternal grandfather Holocaust survivor
once it was in Auschwitz lost his whole
family but had a really great sense of
humor by the time I met him and when he
was in America having lives in America
you know it was and there's that
remarkable contrast between somebody who
seen literally the worst possible thing
you could see and being really funny and
I think that was part of whoa how you
get through that yeah and that's a
powerful lesson as a child to realize
like that's what humor can do is allow
you to get through those kind of things
but to keep your sanity like how do you
keep your like it's a it's a if you went
insane because of what you saw no one
would everyone would understand yeah
yeah but he didn't he was he had a sense
of humor and he was he's incredible and
the other side my Twitter and my
maternal grandmother we used to like
drive around in her Volvo listening to a
2,000 year old man on like cassette tape
and so she really introduced me to like
all those comedians the Mel Brooks and
watching it's a mad mad mad mad world
and really that also stood getting that
part of the humor and the structure
the craft of it yep so I really you know
and obviously my parents are just very
funny and awesome and they have
incredible senses of humor so that just
yeah that's how you make a comedian so
they should have known that you were
gonna perfect all their fault yeah you
did this and then I said did the
stand-up then start in college then was
that first yep
so I was a kid magician I'm so magician
I love magic so much I was 5 years old I
started doing magic tricks I always
loved performing and I would do tricks
what you know I was it I would just
perform at the drop of a hat and I would
have a rabbit no but I am this is the
problem with drinking coffee is I'm just
like I'm gonna end up going faster and
we're talking about like you're sinking
right now is exactly what's happening
you're gonna be like wow his words are
just so fast so fast but yeah I did
magic my whole life went to magic camp
where I'm still a counselor and I love
it tennis magic camp go if your kids
into magic send them it's life-changing
but then I got to college and I had a
fraternity brother who was like yeah I'm
doing this stand-up comedy show and then
you only did it once a year and the
reason I started my group actually was
because I wanted there to be sort of a
home for stand-up constantly not just
one show a year but he was it come to a
do magic you're funny when you do magic
come to our show I was like well why
don't I try stand-up and I did it and
sort of I was addicted I see was like
got on stage and started I was like this
is the art form this is this is the
thing and I think that's I think that's
most comedians is it's a drug yeah and
as soon as you get that first hit you're
like I you become addicted like Steve I
feel like people who book comedy clubs
often feel like drug dealers does he
have all these comics really trying to
scratch the itch like Indian Allen can
you get me on can you get me on and
definitely like that's probably the way
they have the thing about it is that
they have access to this very like
sought-after drug well there's there's I
kind of like to compare someone taking
the stage as a comedian and
making hundreds of people laugh at the
same time I like to compare that to when
someone fills like a sports stadium or
for a music event or something like that
and there's you know 10,000 30,000
people all just in tune with the artist
or the comedian or the performer that's
happening and you know that's one of the
reasons why we want to take these
intellectual discourses and debates and
meditations and comedies and bring them
to the big sports stadium stages because
we love the idea of the thousands of
people all at the same time having that
feeling all together there's an energy
for sure I hosted the ball drop in Times
Square on New Year's Eve and so I got to
talk in front of a million people at
once literally I'm on the stage holding
a microphone and I'm being beamed to a
million people all over Times Square in
New York and there's just this energy
that literally just hits you in the
chest cuz all just all eyes are aimed at
one point yes and it's it's intense it's
crazy total and you just you feel it
it's just it's almost indescribable it
reaches yeah I don't know 4 million
people every day you've run out of
people very quickly you did million
million people sets it would be you do
like seven show so you'd be like done
that may is may that may very well be a
big part of the future of performance is
doing it for that many people I'm like
kind of like the America's Got Talent's
it's a good segue a little bit although
I don't know I mean I think 20 million
people on a TV show is fine like but at
a certain size I think you're calm
because comedy does have to be specific
there's always specificity and so
performing for the whole world your
comedy would have to be broader than if
you're performing for one country I'm
sorry for one state that's a great point
yeah so there is a broadening which
would reduce art if you try to perform
something that makes the whole world
happy yeah it's not gonna be only a very
different art but it's also I think I
might be watered down or it so brought
us to lose its sort of uniqueness to a
degree but then there's also that it's
so broad that you can make it so that
all of the humor is humor
that earth can relate to with you can
maybe talk about things like how complex
the hockey sticking is and how we need
to work together and in fun ways like
something crazy like the genetically
engineered children walking around and
like right I'm seeing like culturally
like I just did a tour in Kazakhstan and
they have to rewrite you're all set not
only was I being translated into Russian
so that's a language barrier thing that
you had to work with this translator who
was incredible we had to work really
hard to figure out how do you translate
these jokes but then even if he
translated me exactly word for word
there's so much cultural different
that's right and so like even saying a
joke where you're like I'm gonna go to
the supermarket if you're performing for
the whole world that doesn't track for
everybody tell me we're like what's a
supermarket yeah or or either word that
you used or in their language yeah it
could be that or even the concept like
the way I you know like the way we treat
women and art you know they're equals
at least obey or Walmart's and Laos but
there are certain countries where like
they're behind culturally in terms of
like women's rights gay rights civil
rights so if you act like it's in a suit
that you take the assumption obviously
women are men are equal yeah which I
would hope would eventually be the
world's thing some countries don't
necessarily believe that right now so
they wouldn't get that joke yeah so like
that's that you know they're people of
all your skin color religion or whatever
if you do a gender like my wife was
driving there's some countries where
they're like what do you mean a woman's
traffic like there's that you know that
there's that like so I had a certain
point you get so high level that you
lose the ability to make jokes there's
like high concepts of like do we all see
red and then you go fetch it there's
colorblind people like there's always
one group yeah that you might so its see
blue many groups opens people up also to
people saying oh well why is it okay for
women to drive there maybe that's
something that we should adapt and
change to so that's also interesting
could be broadening people's
perspectives through jokes like that
okay so that's a really cool part of
this like global picture of comedy now
now what is it like you know working
your way up to doing Last Comic Standing
and Konan and America's Got Talent and
what was that process like them and what
is it like being there do it yes it's
exciting there's a lot of pressure like
America's Got Talent
you know the numbers going in that it's
I think it's 20 million people are
watching an episode so you go from 200
people to 20 million people and you also
realize that like let's say the average
audience size that I'm getting up to
live you know what I'm in a comedy club
200 people yeah you know I'll do I'll do
theatres of thousands of people but even
if I did a thousand people a night in
the number of nights I would need to do
to hit 20 million yeah and I'm doing
that at one set so there's this pressure
of like I'm gonna perform for more
people in this moment than I will in
years of touring even decades of touring
you you don't want to think about that
too much because then you'll psych
yourself out but that's something in the
back of your head so there's a there's a
pressure to that but then like there's
there's a saying like over prepare and
then go with the flow and that's that
sort of my approach to any TV thing is
be way over prepared do the set a
million times run around like before
Conan I got the call I mean it was an
email but I got an email on I want to
say Thursday or Wednesday something like
that it's like Thursday or Friday like
we we're ready because but basically
they approve your set and then it's
about waiting for a slot in an episode
to give you so you get the email like
Friday Thursday Friday you're getting
Tuesday we're gonna fly you out Monday
and you're gonna be on the show twos
they're got a lot of preparations you're
like oh [ __ ] I have four days between
now and Conan yeah not that I haven't
the only way to get to that point in the
set is you've sent them a video it's a
set you've done a million times already
so you've done the hours already
totally but that's but that moment where
you're like okay Conan's in four days I
just called every favor I could I was
like I want to go on stage and run the
five minutes set that I'm doing for
Conan yeah I did 22 shows I think in
like three days
perfect and then boobs I I really ran
that thing like a marathon runner so a
professional does it this is that's
really well done
yeah and Seinfeld used to literally jot
so we felt like a like an athlete like
you would run around like I'm doing my
set over and over again so yeah and so
that's the over-prepare part and then
they go with the flow is you can prepare
as much as you want but if you're a
robot it's you're not gonna deliver the
way you want you're not supposed to be
over repairing so that you can do it
without thinking as soon as you remove
the thinking opponent you're dead so
like even with the set I'm Conan
one of the first things I did was a riff
because they like stood up immediately
since I walked out and I was like I
haven't done anything yet you guys can
sit down and that's obviously not
something you prepare you don't know
that's gonna happen but if I wasn't in
the moment then I wouldn't be able to do
that so the over-prepare
go-with-the-flow is sort of my like
mantra for any of that TV thing it was
like you're gonna do the overpair and
that's good but then you need to give
yourself the freedom to break from the
thing that you've been rehearsing a
million times yeah those are really good
pieces of advice and I like how your
drive is so is so evident there's that
you know you work your ass off to get
the opportunity and then when you get it
you go and you hustle around 22 shows
prior you know to go through the
practice and then you still remain a
presence of really humane presence when
you walk in through the door to be able
to to be there with the audience and
engage with them in a friendly way it
seems kind of crazy to be doing 600-plus
shows not to hear an addict
yeah see how it seems we're often you
want to do heroin like haha so this is
like two to three sometimes at night
oh and of the live o'clock 7 and 9 or 7
911 it's usually way later it's usually
like your first shows around 7:00 or
8:00 comedy before 7:00 or 8:00 can be
weird the comedy is better in the
darkness but yeah I mean you can go it's
a 4 o'clock in the morning sometimes
just running sets and I think the record
I think it did 10 shows in a day was
like my record for most shows and one
24-hour periods bad yeah yeah and so
then now how often are you writing new
material for the different set
always always sometimes like I always
say you have to change something about
every set so every second if you at
least one thing different otherwise
you're not taking in fresh data and
granted you can do the same set to
different audiences and that's gonna be
different but who doesn't work in this
room and this environment but I'm always
trying to change even tweaking one word
or one pause changing where the pause is
so at least I'm trying something new
because if I don't then this that
doesn't ever get better yeah so I'm
always changing a little bit but
sometimes it's massive sometimes I'm
gonna walk out and I've never done this
bit before and you're gonna sandwich it
between bits you know work so you have
cushion but that's the excitement like
as comments always talk about like the
day a new bit works is one of the most
exciting days because you have a new toy
it really kid yeah and you got a new toy
for Hanukkah or Christmas you're like I
have this new thing to play with yeah
cuz you can still play with the old toys
but you play with them for a year and
you're like you're pretty much aware of
how this toy works yeah but then you get
this fresh new toy and then that's the
addiction right is that that you have
this fresh toy so you want to play with
it all the time and then eventually
you've kind of over played with it you
play with it a lot like okay I'm ready
for the next toy boy that's it a good
way to put the specific jokes that
you're writing is that you go and you
land the first time and you're like yes
awesome and then you go tinker with it
and put it into your different sets and
then you you know get old you get sick
of the toy but you already have new
material that you've been testing and
writing that's good that's good it's a
good way to put it
okay so I think this is really important
because I think a lot of young people
don't necessarily even know that comedy
is a it's humor is really important in
our world yeah it's so crucial why
there's a lesson of humor like I've
lectured on how you use comedy in a non
comedy context that doesn't mean have to
be funny but like the less comedians are
all about giving as much information as
possible and as tiny base as possible
it's about compressing yes sort of a lot
of ideas into a tiny space like the
compression algorithm yeah I think the
way poetry works too like motors such a
tiny
faced with all of this stuff in it yes
and so like that's a really good way to
communicate yeah
and humor like being aware of yourself
and how you're being perceived and being
honest and authentic that's the other
thing that comedians are is will tell
you how we feel sometimes if you're
uncomfortable at a meeting or you're
something's happening that's strange
instead of ignoring it just say it I
like the relief that goes through the
room when you're like yeah isn't this
crazy they're like oh my god it was
crazy okay let's fix it why hold that
back so that kind of honesty an
authenticity is a lesson you don't need
to be funny per se you can still learn
that from a comedian I love that the
it's kind of blunt it's very like blunt
honest about the moment instead of
holding things back and releasing
feelings so the compression that you're
talking about this is all it's all super
important how does one figure out when
to enter humor into them because then
there's also people that are really
serious and they are going to be really
serious and so if you're trying to you
know say like oh this is really crazy
isn't it we're all yeah there's a time
and a place for humor for sure like if
you're if something's very if you're at
a funeral like the odds of you making a
killer joke are lower like be
appropriate with who you're with but
yeah I feel like there's definitely
people could use more humor and like
with emails like obviously be careful
you don't want to email the CEO of your
company and like try a joke that might
offend them that's a bad plan but like
sometimes being a little funny is is a
good thing I think we the world the
world on hold needs more humor than less
version yes yes now how does one think
as we will get two kids in a moment how
does one get to knowing how to be
properly you know there's there's a big
uprising of political correctness
happening and a big pricing of people
being offended by
and there's there's a certain amount of
ethics that are evolving although I will
hey because Neal keeps saying that
there's like people are getting more
offended I don't necessarily know if
that's true I think the tools for people
who are offended to be loud and make it
known are definitely like pre-twitter I
think I think people were just as I
think people were always as offended
when you talk about like my heroes from
older generations like your Richard
Pryor your George Carlin your smother
brothers like those guys got a ton of
complaints when they were on television
but they were letters that were mailed
to the TV networks and so you never saw
them unless you were the TV network and
then they could choose whether or not
they responded to them they could be
like what do you mean we got a ton of
letters and then like kick the door
close of the closet and overflowing with
letters we did get any complaints or
they can be like wow we got complaints
we got to cancel this show so I don't
know if the outrage and offense is more
but now a random person can tweet
something and a million people can see
it so that one
one person who was outraged can amplify
his message interesting so I don't know
people are more offended I just think
people are more aware when people are
offended yeah there's an amplification
with exponential technology that's
happened that's interesting and then
then there becomes a really interesting
dilemma as a comedian which is art when
you're responding to offense making sure
that you're not responding to one person
amplified a million times as opposed to
a million people being offended and and
that being one message being sent so
it's figuring out which one it is
because you don't know if the only one
person is offended out of a million yeah
you're probably doing fine but if that
person is allowed as loud as a million
that message has the same volume as a
million people being offended at volume
one yeah I think one of the goals in
many ways of comedy is to help people
evolve their ethics ones that may not be
caught up yet in the equality of
opportunity between men women
people of all different skin colors and
religions and places around the world so
this comedies role is to help people
evolve towards that unity towards that
yeah there are studies from like the 50s
and 60s because in doing my thesis I've
read anything if humor was the keyword
in your psychological article but I read
it and there's all these studies where
they just tell you statements so people
read very serious essays trying to
persuade you about you know why misogyny
is wrong and then there would be a joke
that illustrates why misogyny is wrong
and even though the joke is shorter and
it doesn't have any data the way a
scientific or serious article would
jokes are on whole far more persuasive
at changing attitude then a serious
comment and that's a very powerful tool
like it it the way I looked at it was it
sort of like a like it's like a sneak
attack like you're by the time your
brain realizes that information has been
injected into your brain it's too late
because it's just a joke I listen to the
joke and you're like oh no he hit this
thought in it as opposed to when you
just hear a thought you can immediately
be like do I like this thought or not
until you want to use the tool for good
it can also be used for bad joke or
racist jokes totally punching up first
down yeah yeah I mean to you it's a it's
a any power can be used for good or bad
that's right knowing about physics can
be used to build a bomb yeah make it
also help people yeah so it's the same
thing jokes are a more persuasive thing
than a statement use your power for good
that's a good point
I like that Harrison okay teach us about
why do we see so few examples of kids
being able to enter comedy why is it so
difficult for this process like for kids
like you know children it seems yeah but
children I mean like children in the
sense that when we're young in high
school no one's coming in and saying why
don't you practice speaking in front of
people and telling jokes you know what I
mean and building up a sense of stage
presence building up a getting through
that barrier of fear also practicing
humor practicing it amongst your friends
see I don't think there's enough of that
in the in the early years of children
and
they're anything of like eye if you ask
a five-year-old to write a play it's
gonna be it could be very fun to a hot
but it's not gonna be it's yeah but 14
to 18 year old so have evolved much more
live and so they are much more able to
come up with material I don't know that
even if the fourteen-year-old is now
more advanced I don't know if there
there's a self-awareness that's required
from confident that comes in like maybe
that early 2000 not to say that I
haven't seen some very young comics or
very good yeah but also just
pragmatically sure the way we experience
comic right now is in comedy clubs and
at bars a lot of alcohol and a lot of
adults so I think there is just a
pragmatic thing where comedy is consumed
by adults and adult environments whereas
like is the same thing with a certain
kind of you can see a musical that's
geared for kids and there's adult
musicals yeah yeah so there is room for
it but I do think there is just
pragmatically because the comedy is
consumed in these adult environments
it's harder for a kid to because they're
physically they're legally not allowed
to enter some of these environments yeah
yeah and then they're maybe needs to be
then environments for the younger people
below 21 up to maybe 15 to 21 or why not
for them to be able to go and test their
footing that could be quite interesting
okay that's also the audience right so
if I'm a stand-up comic who's 14 you
it's a very different set if I'm a 14
year old performing for adults versus 14
year old before me for other 14 year
olds that's right
and that will be really interesting to
say that's raised to have teenagers
design stand-up comedy that's really to
be consumed by teenagers that's what I'm
saying there's a lot to poke fun at in
the social media age of how we use the
devices and yeah how we're addicted to
them and if they can start poking fun at
that and getting people to be like okay
we are ridiculous yeah yeah that great
idea that person would have to literally
invent a market yeah because they can't
just go to the comedy club because
that's where adults are showing up so
they're ready to figure out boom we just
have a 3:00 p.m. show where teenagers
are allowed I know we got this that's
what I'm saying yeah the athletes
dominate that between comedy we got
after-school let's make this market
happy at 16 to 20 year old market
okay a couple okay couple last thoughts
on the way out I would love to see that
like we're a 14 year old it was like is
it all right is it having a substitute
teacher amazing like it's like that
there they sit there struggling trying
to pronounce the name of foreign kids in
the classrooms names and they're like
Zack team you knew that was right why do
they even try just be like hi his name
is spelled this way
it's I it's not for me to butcher it why
don't you just tell me how to pronounce
it and I will nail it
where are you gonna make this weird
attempt or they're just like is there a
see this one I'm saying this is good
stuff or like how just how addicted we
are to messaging each other in the
classroom and yapping about things and
it would be a good window I don't know
adults who are like in their 30s but
find that I think really good 14 year
old comedy for 14 year olds should be
unfunny to 30 year olds we should be
like what you're completing about that
because our problems are so much bigger
in a way really weren't about homework
and we're worried about that the world
for oh yeah another say that these we
have all these teenage activists who are
incredible that's right but their their
day to day is is a lot different than
our day to day so sorry yeah and that's
again to bring a full circle of like
performing for the world versus before
you for a specific audience you can do a
lot more when you know your specific
audience so the 14 year old is
performing for a 14 year old there are
some amazing things and then finding out
what's really laughing because when
everyone's laughing that's them saying
oh I feel this way or oh I get it if you
have a room of a thousand 14 year olds
laughing at a problem and I'm an adult
and I hear that I'm like this is a
problem I can fix and make their lives
better just all the all the students now
that have laptops in the classrooms lol
are you actually doing homework right
now no I'm such a hand writer and that's
a dinosaur thing now it's crazy okay a
couple you have a couple quick questions
on the way out
okay first question is what would you
say is a core driving principle of yours
ooh that's that's hard I mean I I I
guess the good example is a Taylor Swift
I did warm-up comedy for Katie Couric's
talk-show so there was a lot of
celebrity is coming through and Taylor
Swift said something that was really
important was there's a difference
between walking on stage and saying Here
I am like you're welcome oh yeah and
walking on stage and saying thank you
for being here thank you for being here
totally yeah and that's my drive is
always that ladder of like I'm in I'm in
service of the audience the audience is
not here to see me per se I'm there to
make you happy I'm - I'm doing all this
work and making all these sacrifices so
that you can have a fun night out and
you can enjoy yourself and you can maybe
you learn maybe it changes how you think
but I'm doing that for you
and so that's the core driver is making
sure at all points that it's not an
exercise and like I want you to see how
good I am
that's not what this is about intro I'm
trying to get good enough so that you
can have this really amazing moment it's
all about that aiming the arrow from the
stage out to the audience I'm aiming
this it's not about what's what the
audience is doing coming towards me
that's right well that may be over some
fight because I am the laboratory I'm
using the laughter all that stuff to do
stuff but it's about me giving you
something as opposed are you giving me
something yes yes very beautifully set a
like core driving principle
we're always we find a lot of our
meaning in life by giving to Taylor
Swift yes that's yeah that's right
it's like we come out with gratitude for
this experience you know the gratitude
to be sitting down with you the
gratitude for you and the viewers that
are watching this and when we carry that
presence it really helps us melt more
into our humanity
unless so in tort eagle and gratitude
practice like I took a class in college
called positive psychology and that was
writing a gratitude journal or telling
people you appreciate them like I'm so
grateful I wrote a letter to my
grandmother for her 80th birthday
Jinta passed away before her 81st I
didn't know that at the time but I wrote
her a letter it was just a gratitude
letter it was just let me tell you why
you're so special to me and it was this
letter that I gave just to her in an
envelope like this is for you read it
later and of course she showed it to
everybody and framed it because she's a
Jewish grandmother but the goal was it
was supposed to be a private thing but
of course the glue do this and she knew
she she always knew how grateful I was I
don't think I ever she never not didn't
know that but that letter meant so much
to her as a result it meant so much to
me that's right and when she did pass it
made it slightly easier to know that she
at least knew how much she changed my
life and so like that gratitude practice
is very very important yeah that's a
really crucial lesson assignment write a
letter to somebody that maybe doesn't
know how grateful you are that's right
we've and we've had an D on our show
before where we've actually talked about
he actually has to say where people can
go and write this letter to people quite
easily about who'd of what they're
grateful for about them and my whole
point being is this is such a great
exercise with your relatives with your
older relatives yeah express the
gratitude that they worked hard to bring
you into the world for and shout out
when we're talking about gratitude
there's Rabbi Brian who's a counselor at
Magic camp he's still a very good friend
of mine he's an amazing person and he
puts out a newsletter he's this thing
called religion outside of the box and
it's all about sort of the it's your
whatever your spiritual understanding is
spiritualism as a practice regardless of
what religion you are he's a rabbi but
it doesn't matter if you're not Jewish
and so like that kind of gratitude
practice like he's such an he's always
about all that stuff so if you're
interested in that kind of stuff in
terms of paying it forward and showing
gratitude I'm grateful to him and I
think he you guys should check him out
you know I can really I'm
really on too much coffee we are we are
plugging our gratitude for people that
I've met that have taught me about
gratitude there we go now okay next
question is if you could rebuild
civilization from scratch how would you
design it ooh if I could build it from
scratch it's funny because you end up in
a Twilight Zone scenario really I'm just
making everybody look identical so that
none of those things are an issue but
then they would just fixate on like the
tiniest microscopic I think that oh this
guy's hair goes this way and this guy's
hair goes that what like so there you
can't fix any of the problems so you
assume that kind of our brains are built
the way they are
I don't even if but even if you like
remove you make sure nobody ever goes
hungry then there's just more and more
people and eventually the world runs out
of resources it's like how do you design
a system I mean I guess the only thing
the most basic thing would be what we're
talking about with making sure everybody
who's born recognizes that they're all
part of the in-group that this idea of
having these arbitrary divisions is
almost never if ever the right solution
sometimes you need it because you need
it but like sometimes you need to
recognize like my family is a unit and I
need to take care of my family
not at the expense of other families but
you need to concentrate on your family
unit and that starts to become in
groupie to a to a degree but you you
always when push comes to shove realize
that we're all part of the same group
and so if you work from that philosophy
that on a whole we have a lot more in
common than different with everybody it
solves a lot of most of the major issues
that we have is about treating everybody
the same regardless of what who they are
you know that's a really good first
principle of the root of the design is
to have everyone understand we're all on
the in-group of Earth in yeah group of
Earth it's just it's one step past do
unto others as you would do unto
yourself because that's almost selfish
is like what they like if I like it then
they'll like it to a degree this is
about just recognizing that everybody is
in the same group we're all on the same
team yeah team human C team human team
earth that should be emerged there is a
team human yeah we got we got a Douglas
rushkoff is a good friend and we're
really excited featuring him soon he's a
big advocate on team human he's read a
book on oh there you go
yeah any royalty we have a lot of
whoever was that we have like a lot of
cool team human merch that's uh
with our own themes and stuff that's
amazing um last two question closes I
will get to sports gear yeah yeah team
human yeah now um last few questions
first one is wouldn't be simulation if
we didn't ask you are we in a simulation
ooh
would I know if I was in a simulation
that's really the question I mean after
the Truman movie came out there was a
huge rise in people believing they were
they were Truman who knows I think we
all watch that movie we're like wait a
second look checking behind cabinets for
cameras like we would never know and so
I guess the point is to just be the best
person you can be like the other core
motivator for me and I think if I'm
building a simulation it all connects is
to leave the world a better place than
what I entered it I don't know if it's
going to be a small amount better or a
large amount better but leave it better
and I think that whether we're in a
simulation or not that principle still
applies if it's if we're in the matrix
it's kind of more of a waste to make the
matrix better then that's your ultimate
test is to continue levelling up and
making this place better and y'all
kissing on that that's your test in the
simulation that's the test yeah so
whether it's a simulation or not yeah
yeah and we'll be able to poke and prod
at the at the
soon to figure out figure it out I think
hopefully oh yeah okay and last question
Harrison what's the most beautiful thing
in the world the beautiful most
beautiful thing in a work in the world
I'm a comedian so that's probably make
when somebody laughs they really laughs
that's a beautiful thing and if you can
give that gift to somebody it's it's
wonderful it's really wonderful when
people are legitimately laughing so hard
you know there's no there's no better
compliment after a set when somebody
comes up and I've had a really rough
week or month or a year at firt that
those moments you were onstage I forgot
about it and I was really happy that's
amazing
so yeah for me is it community most
beautiful thing in the world is making
somebody laugh yeah that's why I'm a
comedian I love that and whenever I'm
laughing my ass off
rolling around on the floor right when
I'm doing that those moments are so
precious I just try to hold them up
there that's so precious and you're
right when someone comes up to you and
tells you about how you possibly
impacted their life that's really
credible yeah so this has been really
enlightening thank you so much for you
joining us i'm joanne talking to us it's
been a pleasure Harrison thank you so
much Matt yeah Godspeed on all of your
endeavors everyone check out the links
below to Harrison's work in his bio also
go and go go and go and go and push
yourself out into uncomfortable
circumstances and situations where you
can really test yourself into the world
find a meaning through that process go
and enter some jokes into into the world
and really put care with Canaris happen
to be like put a joke in the middle of
like their email to there see you there
with care with care yes and also go and
you know support Harrison support us
join us in our efforts so we can
continue doing cool things like coming
out on sites of great places like New
York Jenner
great leaders like Harrison also go and
build the future everyone manifest your
destiny into the world we love you so
much and like don't justify it with
manifest destiny yeah that was your does
definitely yes bill doesn't run period
in American history this is mine now
hold sure everyone we love you yeah as
one we love Tim human-to-human much love
that's a good piece